hey everyone solo a Star Wars story is
now in theaters and we are here with our
review did this movie overcome the
negative press surrounding its
production and did it honor the
character of Han Solo the way we know
and love him in Harrison Ford's
portrayal in the original films well we
got some deeper thoughts on these
questions in this spoiler review but
first welcome to numerix nerves news
everyone it's our deep dive into all the
biggest stories this week so we're also
gonna talk about the upcoming spider-man
movie Deadpool the Boba Fett movie and
this whole box Disney deal that's gonna
control all of our lives how can there
be a new spider-man movie if that
happens this is yeah one topic leads to
the next in this episode you're in for a
treat joining me at this table are my
best friends hello they don't know him
over here and we're have a very similar
color scheme here hey we just swapped
real fast during that cut you didn't
notice well guys let's get started with
our top story our review of solo a Star
Wars story we all saw the movie and
again we're gonna discuss some major
plot details and twists so spoiler
warning go go watch the movie then come
meet us back here okay all right guys
there's been a lot of pressure on this
movie to overcome some bad press and and
I would say the new Z hasn't gap among
fans uncertain over whether we really
needed a han solo origin story or maybe
some were just still a little
overwhelmed after the last Jedi but let
us start by talking about the highlights
what and what ways do you think solo
beat the odds that you should never tell
me didn't work how did this movie
surprise you in a good way well it looks
like this I think everyone needs
technology right out of the gate
everybody has shut up about alden
ehrenreich his performance was totally
fine it was goodness he was not a bad Oh
Dina oh no
smells like burning I thought that he
was not doing an impersonation uh and
yet was still honoring the spirit of the
character and I kept trying to like
great him for like you know half the
movie I was like are you doing a good
job we kept doing that in my head and
eventually I realized like oh I stopped
thinking about that which must mean that
I'm like really buying into this guy and
this character I feel like someone
disagrees we're only saying nice things
now we have those inhibitor collars get
to them say in any freebase I don't need
individual little cupcakes in my
birthday party do I like that of course
they do at least that exists you are not
consulted about whether or not hey do
you guys need transformers I mean no but
every movie you love you didn't also be
a I need it I don't know your buzz word
for that is is it fatigue is this is
this French yeah lucky the money if
anything this fatigue any genre for me
that's fatigue is crime cuz it's just
like there's so many different like wait
there's a person missing we have to
figure it out in the end it's always the
same beats it's like wait a second I was
a person we anyways so I can't do a
whole thing piece on that if we want to
but fatigue of something yeah but no
we're not it
I don't feel fatigue for this I don't we
don't need these movies it's just go
watch it just to enjoy because that's
the point of movies even come away with
something if you learn something if you
didn't if you had a good time and they
wouldn't then they want yeah then the
studio one attacking like some gripes
I've seen out there there I saw
specifically Han Solo's answering the
questions and no one asked and it's like
but second it's kind of like is it every
movie like you again you did not know
that you would want to know this story
hopefully it's an interesting story and
then you're glad you heard it but do you
ever like go in knowing that you're
about to hear a really interesting story
yeah I mean 1977 George Lucas answered
questions that nobody asked who's like
whatever space bears
if you say you're gonna happen to us Han
Solo origin story then immediately I
have questions because it's like when
you see you look at the expensive Canon
here most people don't know that han was
actually married during during a new
hope he had a wife during that and
that's now canon and it's like what and
I want to know are they going to use any
of the comic Canon the comics yes yes
yeah but are they gonna ever use that in
other different types of genres like the
movies Ram and then you get Keira all of
a sudden I'm like man this guy man
but it's like alright that's
understanding human as a character but
other things like that like I I wanted
to know a little bit more but all you
got is how did he meet Chewie how they
get the Millennium Falcon I already know
what the Kessel run is for people how
the castle I never works do you now know
what that means so it's like as like I
definitely know enough people who've
explained it to me but I've never been
I've always just kind of like stored
that information and be like okay I kind
of know what that is yeah but in this in
this case I was like oh it's fun that we
got to explore what that means exactly
and that basically the movie was
structured around like explaining what
that is yeah and I think if you can
detach yourself from those kind of
expectations you're in for a real fun
ride of a movie I think it's fun
this whole middle section the movie the
moment Chewie comes into the story it
becomes a delightful movie in some ways
if you can look at Chewie as the star of
this story and no other Star Wars movie
scene Chewie takes a starring role and
he was so delightful in this movie to
see their relationship evolved over the
course of the film yes I had some gripes
with it but if you can just like take
out the middle section in this movie and
just look at one second act that's
really fun and well-structured I think
that's what you're gonna what you're
gonna get with this movie it's it's just
something that's like not gonna answer
and satisfy every demand you would have
as a fan but like gives you a couple
shining moment so you can hang your hat
on right well that's the whole purpose
of an anthology of anything right it's
like okay we have now endless stories to
tell so let's tell some things in this
story oh you're still curious about
other things great we have endless
stories that will be coming out every
year forever but just so again just say
on some positive things about this film
loved l3
yeah I thought out there was a great
hand off from k2s Oh from
one where you know k2s I had started
this idea of me really feeling
emotionally connected to to a droid and
that in in this movie they kind of like
took that and went even further where
I'm I mean that was the emotional like
shot through my heart and in the movie
was when when we lose out three and then
I actually loved this idea of it's
almost the Johnny Five is a live idea of
like droid almost having a soul and then
that soul is what makes the Millennium
Falcon special and I was like that's
awesome well they went it's really hard
to do what they're doing they're going
back and they're adding meaning to
things we already know about and so to
do it in a way we're like you said you
line things up that that already had
been established and then you gave it
more meaning where they always refer to
the ship as she why is the ship so
special how is this ship so fast it's
not the ship it's the ship's ability to
do this thing i I thought that was like
one of the most masterful things they've
added to the Star Wars universe in
recent history
I like Rio I really enjoyed Rio Duran
you guys cracked me how to say that in
the comments that's not the point that
John that's good I love the physicality
of that character Leyla I like what he
stood for I like it he was just an
enjoyable it kind of reminds me like any
role that Joe Pesci's ever been in like
it was just I enjoy that character and
of course bummer we don't get more of
him
same with l3 and I that was those were
my two favorite characters as a casual
Star Wars fan I enjoy them the Star Wars
movies i watch I know a lot of people
don't agree with me that I don't like
rogue one I think it's got a lot of
problems sleep during it I saw all of
its dreams and the other half is in the
my math teacher showed up because before
I actually really enjoyed this movie and
I think it's sitting at Rotten Tomatoes
at like a 71% right now I'm like yep
bump it up a little bit but not to not
it's mm at most it's like barely a
b-minus it's not a it's not a home run I
enjoyed it the anti I loved everything
that I wanted to love in this the alien
design I dug their relationship and how
they set it up every new character for
the most part I was like
I can deal with this and and the
performances across the board were like
good to great yeah it embraced joy in a
way that a lot of recent Star Wars
movies haven't but I really did love
rogue one and I and I loved the last
Jedi but like it felt like all the joy
in the last Jedi was moved over to this
weird sea plot on the casino planet that
because the movie as a whole was about
much deeper more serious themes it felt
like joy there was no place for joy in
that movie but because it was a Star
Wars movie they had to force joy in it
whereas this movie I think is more truly
about joy yeah it didn't miss out on
some of the emotional stakes that I feel
like as a viewer I needed but like if
you can just like you know and enjoy the
fact that like this is fun I think there
is a place for that in the Star Wars
world if you remember like the very
first Star Wars you know that it was a
movie purely about joy and and the
stakes weren't really that clear until
the final French movie the minutes no
like I feel like I as a kid when I was
watching the first Star Wars I didn't
really understand the Galactic Empire
Civil War the trench run yeah stakes are
ultimately high and you get it but like
for the first two-thirds of that movie
you're just on the on a ride that's fun
yeah so I think that l3 and Lando were a
better GOI than Han and Chewie come at
me but I really really enjoyed the
dynamic together I thought that there
was more for G I felt like that's a
negative mode come on the cinematography
was incredible I think I did amazing
things through the sets I really think
they told a story incredibly well
visually I think I thought it looked
amazing I thought they took a few risks
that didn't feel as star war was asked
yeah but that really enhanced the the
storytelling with honestly the shots
around the Millennium Falcon during on
the mining planet I felt like that
bright scene was really really well done
with ECAM stuff running through the
halls around that and then the car chase
scene yeah I was gonna say for me that
first sequence it I mean to me it was
like watching American Graffiti have you
seen that yeah but it's like which is
this slightly and not to George Lucas
yeah exactly like a 1970s car chase
movie it kind of is this idea of like
joy with steaks
so the Padre scenes in Phantom Menace
are like joy right
who cares yeah this takes like four
steaks and then this is almost the exact
same mechanics of the moment and like oh
no is he gonna make it
and that low shot to the ground kind of
two cars going like an American Graffiti
I keep saying that because it's a 1970s
looked and that brown angle of the city
almost feels like Detroit Harrison
Ford's and then Ron Howard which is
weird but this was like doing that
correctly and adding a new flavor to the
Star Wars universe I really appreciated
that I also really liked the villains
plural like I thought that they did a
really good job of like no matter where
you turn someone else is trying to get
you and that really does embody what it
is to be a scoundrel and I for what
seems like a pretty predictable movie
and they were hurt sometimes it was slow
but we're focusing on positives um the
third act oh I didn't see that coming
yeah and I thought that that was
surprising pleasantly a lot of the way
they brought a lot of the aliens to
light for me that's something that I
always go to these movies like being
really excited if we're gonna do a space
movie there's gonna be aliens say like
let's get as creative as possible like I
really enjoyed the think my favorite
scenes are both of the gambling scenes
like I really liked that the way that
Han and Lando I was like as again casual
fan I'm like aren't they closer friends
it's like no they're not really they're
not like they just deal they're okay
with each other like right they kind of
owe each other things and that's about
it
oh yeah I like to pound on the table ah
but um I enjoyed those things and seeing
those aliens and also like Paul Bettany
a lot of this like he say he's like yeah
I was there for like two days I might
get very clear you did all your scene
yeah maybe two different places you know
you also texted and he said how am I not
in this movie and they were like let's
have a meeting and they put him in the
movie he was it was to Ron Howard yeah
which means pretty late and why not in
the Star Wars movie they did a lot of a
major restructuring of reshoots with Ron
Howard and that's what I feel like the
whole second act did feel like it was
part of a different director role it was
full restructuring I think it was
reshoots cuz mostly they said they just
actually reshot close-ups right so like
originally that character was played by
Kevin James and then they but they
didn't change the writing so much as
that's true the yeah because it was
still the
Kasdan father and son who are writing
exactly script the whole way through
we've been very polite guys let's
release the hounds like okay so we this
wasn't a perfect
yeah let's release the Karelian hounds
yeah and let's take our gripes not a
perfect movie okay it's it's not a
perfect movie so what could this movie
have done better to B's I'm gonna give
you these okay so the first issue I have
is with dandy Newton's character we're
cool character great actress completely
wasted and in if you what watched again
you'll be like wait why is she about to
kill herself for a whole sequence that
is not gonna matter in one minute yeah
like if she had just been around like a
few minutes more out of it and like Han
let's go up the payload anyway it's like
so she thinks she's like I'm saving the
day I'm doing it and then she and that
doesn't matter it's okay and that's the
second time in a Star Wars movies a huge
plot has happened for no reason oh my
god the last Jedi are you kidding me oh
sorry yeah so many people died oh yeah
yeah and then the whole casino part like
for no good reason I thought that movie
was for no good reason there was a great
purpose to showing the mountain being
like absorbed or whatever from that
explosion there like this is how serious
this stuff is but that was great and
introduced the Marauders well but she
didn't need to die and especially
considering the fact that Woody
Harrelson's character doesn't actually
spend like the rest of the movie like I
can't go on like hey cool I'll end it
now if she just saw how in love they
were they didn't make anything what and
I think maybe that's teasing this idea
that there was a greater purpose to what
they were doing or she was like look if
we don't do this they're gonna kill us
anyway I'm sure there's versions of
justifying it picture the movie without
we're dying picture her being in the
rest of the movie awesome that's a
better movie I agree and if at the end
the twist she didn't see it coming
because she didn't know that
she was being betrayed as well like them
extra layers my thing is it is so
surface level and I think that this is
where the huge divide is coming a lot of
the fans are bigger fans of Star Wars
that really know the franchise and
really really love Star Wars are gonna
get disappointed in this movie because
there isn't much payoff really to be a
long-term longevity like the Star Wars
fans of decades we don't get much out of
it it's like cool already knew that
or do you knew that already knew that
why am I here and I feel like they
played it super safe and honestly like I
just didn't get much out of it I was
there was a real long pause there where
the tie like the pacing had just slowed
right down and I was like I'm not
enjoying this movie and that's not what
you want at all
I'm talking like the end of this sort of
the first act going into the second act
there was just a lot of storytelling I
think is before the Kessel run or maybe
even during the Kessel run you're like
calm on like this is this is my idea
maybe in the second second part also
people that have watched this movie that
loved it
have either never seen Star Wars before
are they super new to it and I'm
noticing that the same great example you
don't love Star Wars it's just something
that you kind of you're very impartial
like you're very passive toward the
whole thing the closest thing you had to
a Star Wars shirt it's a good ride like
it's it's a fun adventure to be clear
also before we started recording I
equated to enjoying this as much as I
enjoyed rampage just we need to put that
out there they're equal in my brain
they're kind of forgettable
so Star Wars pen event if you're size
fan and then you see it be like a
rampage movie you can understand why I
am gutted five is because it should have
been and could have been so much more so
your expectations on what I'm allowed to
have expectations but that's what it is
that you're kind of like saying is like
it wasn't good enough don't give me a
character that's been around for thirty
years and then tell a dull like story
behind it I don't think there's a way
this movie could have been better I I
think I just told you 110 Dean's
character not dying okay so that's
better but like Oh Hans story we're not
gonna get there would have been other
problems with with any nude and
surviving throughout the whole movie
this is like III didn't totally love
this movie to me it's
like a bee bee - maybe but like I I
don't I think fundamentally doing a han
solo origin story on it has a very low
ceiling and there's not gonna get an
a-plus maybe out of this one and then
you could go different places with the
Han Solo trilogy or something where he
essentially is Jason Bourne doing this
sure but like he has mischief and
adventures and it's almost a show even
you can imagine cartoon shows yeah fair
enough and then maybe they like a series
or so in the short run like eight
episode arc or something on this new
Disney streaming device that's going to
control all of our households in a
couple years but I to me like I think
there is a place for just fun low stakes
space adventure that essentially is what
thor ragnarok was and what in my opinion
both of a Guardians movies were and I
loved all three of those movies this did
not live up to that just because it
didn't have that sense of color and
ensemble energy that all those movies
would have been the difference with the
other directors maybe you know that's
the thing I came out of this I was like
oh I totally see how this movie could
have been funnier because it's not that
funny a movie it's about as funny as a
the Star Wars movies have been lately it
felt less fun maybe yeah it also felt
like because if if Ron Howard mainly did
reshoots or finished whatever they
wherever they ended up there are like
moments where it felt like there was an
improv line and I was like but this this
is is that because I wear it because it
didn't say if it started out as an
improv movie that I'm like okay for some
reason this part of the universe works
this way and we're gonna just go ahead
and run with that and that's okay like
Thor Ragnarok the hole right there in
joke land wherever the Grand Master I
want to be yeah I'm okay with that
yeah but then like all of a sudden like
when correct me with characters names
Woody Harrelson's character is using the
gunner on the outside of the Millennium
Falcon he's trying to shoot people when
they're flying around it gets ripped off
and he's like my thumb's hurt and it's
like beep beep beep are we the way did
you get hold of her laughs at there
again there's a couple of jokes like
that I'm like just keep going like I
just want to keep going it it didn't
totally work for me and I understand
your point and they for for me it did
show me some new sides to the Star Wars
universe but you're coming in with all
this knowledge from like comic books
today novels are TV shows that like have
may be handled stories like this better
from a fan standpoint I get I understand
that but if you are a casual fan you fly
casual you will be fine with this why
I'm being that fan right now I'm being
that I'm identifying that I'm
gonna say something as well that could
get me a little bit of height or it
could actually get everyone to agree
with me I thought that Donald Glover
overacted from time to time well okay
here's here's why I'll go out on a limb
with you and I'll say Maude is
completely alone on this and amazing
I think watch Donald Glover oh well I'm
gonna throw out there actually on his
SNL run just now where he's hosting us
and he was I mean that shows him like
doing so many different things that
Donald Glover can do and some of them
it's like I don't have a strong angle on
this so I'm gonna hit it ten times
harder that right I know what you're
talking about he's still so good that
you're kind of like you know what he's
good at him at his thing but I actually
do know where don't know where he turns
it on
sometimes aggressively to cover up the
fact that he doesn't he might not have a
clear take on it got it yeah but him a
lot actually throughout but I at least I
know what you're talking just a couple
of times like when the jokes don't land
you're like oh and then it was like a
couple of things that he would do where
he would just overact a little bit or
you're right just ramped it up a little
bit unnecessarily and you're like ooh
but I do think that Donald Glover did a
better lando than Alden did with hon
interest on greed
yeah probably yeah I they are equal in
my head they're like all if you said in
like a generic cutout of an accurate it
was like and he's doing a role of what
an adventurer who's a scoundrel and he
wants to be an outlaw and he's in love
it's like cool so that's movie is like I
don't I'm not connecting but I get
what's happening but with Lando it's
like any years.they you Billy Dee
Williams impersonation a little bit but
you still get some a Donald Glover's
Flair it it didn't Wow me at all and I
was a bit of a bummer but chewy I still
really enjoy it I call the physicality
also I think it's not fair that they hit
the like the third act is all in a
desert and you made that actor walk
around
and I was not I was surprised to hear
you guys had all mentioned that you
liked the third act and he saw that
twist as a surprise really cheesy I
thought it was really dull I love this
the heist sequence on the cake which
part got it all does the moment they
bring the contracts iam back to that
dune planet and the reveal of to which
was super confusing right like like the
reveal of these other people and and
felt like inserted and there was nothing
throughout the movie that was
establishing why Han would care about
these kind of people and suddenly we had
to view this as this is when Han becomes
Han the good guy I mean the entire third
act felt like it was part of a different
movie and it was not interesting to
parallel stories where we had the
deception and you had you know that all
the stuff with Paul Bettany I thought
was great I really really enjoyed that
the battle sequence they've got new
weapons I was like kill that satisfied
me as a Star Wars fan but then you're
right it would cut back to this or you
would go straight off that high into
this really boring kind of reveal your
and it was super cheesy personally for
me was like oh let's be the good people
when Disney has focused so hard on
trying not to differentiate that is good
and bad it's just dark and light you
know every no one's wrong but this one
was so hard do the right thing I felt
like a man was gonna come out after this
episode and tell me don't drink kids you
know like that's where that was going
also this the speech that she had is a
really great moment she's a great
actress but when you put exposition in
the final act right and that's a that's
a big do it well okay I'm gonna bridge I
think maybe your two thoughts right
there because the key you can do
exposition of the third act but it has
to be a question that you've had the
entire movie that you're desperate for
the answer to and you know you're saying
like unearned and that's why that works
like oh I didn't have this question so
it feels like janky just jammed and
ideally in your third act you're really
just recycling lines that you've already
used throughout the movie and now they
just have new meaning right and that's
in like ideal world of screen I know
scrutinise very hard and you know the
Kasden father
we're amazing therefore better writers
than I am so I'm not gonna tell them how
to write but it just go
I just emotionally I felt attached from
that third act and I think to their
credit what they were trying to do the
moment Han shoots Beckett I think was
meant to have some real dramatic payoff
han shoots first this is who shot who
han is it shoots his father essentially
was a figure yeah it uh but the reasons
he does it are for people that we do not
care about yeah and we have had been
given no reason to care about them in
the preceding hour and and he knows
nothing about
he had one person who has been kind of a
criminal like even if they stand they we
hear them say that they are
self-important even though we have
literally no evidence of them doing
anything to benefit anyone else and it
was I agree I now think I honestly
haven't thought about that more I was
just like I was just waiting for it to
be done when the fight happened between
Emilia Clarke and Eldon and Paul Bettany
I was like I'm enjoying this this is
very cool the way they're using their
weapons but overall the story is just
like mmm yeah he's a father figure but
when did he teach him anything besides
about don't trust people it's like right
fathers teach more things fathers are
more important they never had one
emotional connecting moment like if you
realize that he was caring for him and
like tried to stop himself going gosh
I'm actually it's seeing him as like a
son if you had that moment that would
have been a much better payoff you know
he would have felt something ya know
just to contrast here I'm gonna say I
still like the twist and I really mean
that literally of the plan of I I didn't
trust you and I assumed you were
actually gonna turn your back on me so I
have you know that whole thing I
actually really liked that specifically
I'm not defending the marauders thing
because I think actually we're gonna
make another video about this actually
who they really are what their deal
really was it was jammed into one
sentence really quick as part of like a
big reveal to and it felt like oh this
that went by way too fast so it's very
interesting but it I agree that unearned
feeling and I'll throw out there there's
a question I think a lot of people have
right now that goes along with how
rushed that whole moment is is it me and
answered yes to or no because other
people told me that agree I were they
trying to also put off and
Enver inverting business and business
was potentially woody harrelson and Andy
Newton's daughter it seemed version of
the script that that might was talked
about like she was talking about her mom
and then the way that dandy and and
woody harrelson Beckett I had talked
about her coming it was very reminiscent
to me of Leia and Han talking about kylo
in force awakens where they know there's
this problem that's gonna return to them
and I haven't dealt with it yet and so I
was like oh they're setting up this is
gonna be her daughter and they kind of
just didn't acknowledge that and I think
that's another reason where it's like oh
I feel like we're all missing a lot of
information about why these people are
more important and what's going on yeah
I think and there was also just a lot of
confusion over why the hell is Darth
Maul here how is this possible it is
possible we're also gonna be doing
another video though it was cool I love
that he's older to really like he's from
the other trilogy yeah right yeah but it
was only five people in the theater that
was pretty big so it was just like yeah
we know who Darth Maul is and I'm I'm
excited about them and they were like it
was as if that someone was giving out
free stuff from the movie like alright
we got we're excited
I can't hear what he's saying right now
so I don't know what this is but
whatever like read online what he said
but I was just like this is calm down
everybody I've been in one in some ways
it's it's actually the most little
definition of fanservice where but it
but who cares cuz I loved it it's one of
the first time or one most obvious times
where they were like you know everyone
just says like they hated the prequels
but behind they wasted darth maul's such
a cool character and then actually we're
pretty familiar with canon so we do know
that that character was just sitting
there available to come back but there
really were like hey let's bring him
back let's do it he's the best thing
about they brought back to all other
faiths quick question the Star Wars
theme exists in the world of Star Wars
because it plays during the regreted
Imperial March yeah I had a lot of
questions in this movie like what was it
was one I was like so Chu he's
definitely eating those prisoners they
put down there right yeah there were
shells of things it was like yeah Chewie
eats those yes
he was rankle about uh like also throw
ragnerok since we bringing that back up
I'm like Thor might be eating those
aliens that he's marking they are not
Thor I mean well there's a lot of
questions and there's a lot we have to
move on but yet because I said I had to
I'll say it in one sentence the other
thing I didn't like it's a plot hole
that they invite emilia clarke at all
they literally have just said we can't
be associated with this and they're like
well you won't because it's us and they
don't know that we're with you and he's
like great send my first lieutenant with
you she's got a tattoo of my symbol they
won't figure that part out I was like
that was a meaty back-to-back pothole
yeah looking at a lot of these things we
have a full easter egg breakdown coming
up so keep an out on our channel and
yeah send us your questions that you
have because we'll be talking about solo
this is gonna be our last Star Wars
movie for a long time so nine comes out
and a Boba Fett movie at some point that
we will be talking about in this episode
but yeah let us know in the comments
down below and keep an eye out for our
pipeline for all these other things but
for now let us move on to our trivia
question and we're gonna keep because we
don't need a lot of room to answer this
question when hands look bigger George
Lucas originally conceived of the
character of Han Solo he based Han
smooth-talking swagger on a famous
director who was that director our
questions are in this bin and later will
real the answer the question and the
winner has decided by our judges will do
our sign-off good-byes at the end of the
video meanwhile the loser will have to
cleverly riff on our in other news
headlines but let us move on and before
we continue with some Star Wars news
let's quickly check in on some other big
news that dropped this week because yeah
we want to cover all the big stories
need to know about here
spider-man Home Coming sequel is rumored
to feature Jake Gyllenhaal as Mysterio
now Mysterio is a master illusionist
known for his fishbowl style helmet now
this news actually contradicts the
rumors that we were talking about that
gelila in hall hall could be taking over
the role of Batman from Ben Affleck in
the DC EU
you know he denied but we were still
hoping do you have a problem with people
that I have to double letters in their
last name it's just fun to say it weird
he doesn't know that's how it said you
guys are the weird one now actually
Gyllenhaal will join Michael Keaton who
is set to return as the vulture in
Spider Man sequel loved that spider-man
movie seek out of as many villains as
possible Logan the comics Mysterio was
there one who that would that be fine
spoiler Mysterio makes Wolverine Logan
imagined that every one of his friends
at the academy is actually a villain and
so he kills them all
okay everybody some big Star Wars news
dropped this week alongside the solo
premiere the upcoming Boba Fett movie
will be written and directed by James
Mangold best known for directing Logan
last year and the Wolverine in 2013 now
Fantastic Four reboot director Josh
Trank was originally attached to direct
the movie but he left the project in
leave advance to wonder he walked away
from that too he's fantastic forward
yeah yeah and he he is working on some
Al Capone movie that's coming out but
anyway we were all wondering if Boba
Fett was even gonna happen as a movie
the Bounty Hunter has always been a fan
favorite director from the original
trilogy even Utley famous only they have
like four or five lines a dialogue and
the die to bury on ceremony instead
falling in the Sarlacc pit on Tatooine
but people love this guy and we saw a
young version of Boba Fett of course in
the prequels the clone son figure to
Jango Fett on Kamino and attack of the
clones we last saw him on Geonosis yeah
it's all there George aiesec eat all of
it but he was on Geonosis holding Jango
severed head in the Mandalorian star one
helmet that he'd probably inherit
he's really pissed off it falls out of a
shell now but James Mangold has taken
over this guy's it's very exciting we're
still waiting for confirmation on the
story of what exactly's boba Fett movie
will be you'll probably show it's time
as a bounty hunter
piloting slave 1 between the events of
clones and the first appearance of
Empire Strikes Back but choosing James
Mangold as a director of this project
suggests that Lucas bones looking for a
tone that's
and gritty violent maybe a little
Western II what elements do you guys
think from mega let's work in Logan do
you think could really work the best
going into a Boba Fett movie honestly he
probably would have done an okay job may
be equal to or better with a han Solo
movie to if you wanted because there was
a western you feel to this to just solo
i if lean into the Western because I
feel like Star Wars fans are still gonna
be kind of disappointed with this movie
like no matter what like I don't feel
like that's what's gonna happen looks at
me when you said that I just like this
feel I do I can see this conversation
happening in the future where it's just
like it's not gonna it's not be perfect
but I think he can have some fun with if
he were to lean more into his Western
roots he did it 3:10 to Yuma and
Wolverine and Logan and everyone loves
him for those movies so aim for that and
I think will be happy I just don't see
fans being happy with this movie I could
just see it as a bear time basically
entire story was totally open that's a
good that's kind of like what Samus said
previously was people are like do we
need it and it's like you don't know no
no until they somebody writes a story
that might be the best story ever told
yeah it's Casablanca with Boba Fett or
something but yeah I think it could be
great and something from Logan that I
think he could take I don't know if you
guys felt this vibe at least the
character of Logan did he was painted as
if he's an antihero as if he's been the
villain previously because that's where
he's at mentally by the time that
movie's taking place and so he feels
like look I'm a bad guy even though we
all like cheer for Wolverine he feels
like he's a bad guy and the fact that
then the rest of movie it's like whoa
even if he feels like a bad guy how do
you get him to come out and do something
for at least one good reason how do you
get him to save his soul
this guy's a bounty hunter and I think
that he could go through a similar thing
of like look I'm a bounty hunter for a
very specific reason and that's a path
I've chosen but is there something that
I'm not necessarily saying you have to
do that thing where it's like but
there's kids to save you know I'm there
to the cliff whatever like it doesn't
have to be that but there is a way to
make it so that Boba Fett can be someone
that we want to root for and and
emotionally connect with even though we
only know how much I belong yeah it'd be
fun to see like so James Mangold I I'm
very excited to see it like the way he
can humanize a character who's kind
become a bit of a joke to some people
like you think when he took over
Wolverine after x-men origins that was
like the lowest possible point and the
Wolverine adaptations on film and then
when he took over in the Wolverine and
with Logan it's like he brought a new
humanity the character that we're all
dying to see I recently watched a movie
that was a Western called
Wind River it's with Jeremy Renner is
and he plays a hunter who ends up like
doing his way of solving a crime on a
reservation a woman's raped and she dies
and he has to work with an FBI agent to
uncover what really happened and it was
this great western and I really it's not
really Jeremy Renner's character's story
as much in it he's just his character
doesn't really change there's like a
detective story it's a detective story
the way he starts the movie is the way
he ends it and I don't know if I really
want to see boba fett transition I'd
rather just see him as this badass
character who just like picks up
whatever this case is if it's like
chasing down someone who got away with
some crime and he has to go find them
and like Clint Eastwood Unforgiven style
where he just becomes who he is meant to
be kind of a that's killer a film or
thing - yeah I do like this the story
where it can go so in Clone Wars Boba
Fett is raised by bounty hunters and you
have really cool characters like bosque
who basically looks like a dinosaur and
a tree trunk got combined but like a lot
of fun because in the video games you
played it as a boss character and then
there's like a sniper I forget her name
but she's awesome sexy girl but having
like this full-on unit I could see it
being like a suicide esque squad kind of
thing where they're all working together
probably on some of the bounties and
they're probably splitting it but
they're also trying to deceive each
other and then you know it's like that
element which I think could be a lot of
fun the one thing that I really really
hope doesn't happen which did happen in
episode 7 what was that one course
wiggins thank you which is when you
introduced to the character Kyler the
average person has only ever seen him
with his helmet on and when Kyler was
first introduced you only saw him with
his helmet on and then he took his
helmet off and everyone laughed
everyone laughed in the two times I
watched it in cinema everyone laughed
and I'm scare
that when you finally do reveal who this
Boba Fett character could be that as
soon as you have a face that's kind of
like revealed when it's the helmet that
so iconic that it lets people down
we know indication though what he
probably looks like maybe but yeah
there's something common interesting if
you don't show his face too if you if it
like maybe you never saw Adam driver
like what if he took it off and you only
see em back behind so you only see like
he's got like brown hair that's all you
know but like generally that's a really
interesting kind of like yeah it if it
were more in the Western vein of it he
is like a legend he is like the ghost
rider who comes through a town and he
leaves again like you better there's
something there that you can kind of
flair I like all that I don't agree with
the idea of not seeing his face I think
it's like a fundamental inherent thing
that we have to connect with eyes and
like it's why I think it was such a
breakthrough that spider-man's
eyes could change or also Deadpool's
eyes are pretty animated too it's like
otherwise you are just looking at a
machine unless you pair him with someone
who has so much humanity their character
and he that character becomes a foil for
his behavior to so we were able to
identify with Boba Fett's during heaven
James James about Bubba Fett which I
think could be worth exploring is the
actual planet of Mandalore like we
haven't really gone to mandala before
and that's where obi-wan is really
heavily involved and it could be a
really good tying together I actually
wouldn't mind seeing well those people
are fascinating to like they
consistently are some of the best
characters and when you were touching on
the idea of like his crew like it'd be
fun to see like assassins as a crew we
kind of keep thinking that we're gonna
get the the Dirty Dozen and they're
really like tough criminals and stuff
and we kind of keep not kidding you know
yeah movies now yeah well let us know
what you're hoping to see from this Boba
Fett movie and what you liked most about
Logan that you hoped could translate
over into this Star Wars universe now
that James Mangold is doing this but
okay another update of news you need an
ovum this week Deadpool to director
david leitch confirmed that he does plan
to release an extended cut that's 20
minutes longer than the release version
of Deadpool 2 now we know from trailers
that there was a lot of footage that was
not used alternate jokes some footage of
the x-force members like that woman
shatter star in action even though that
was probably shot just to make their
sudden death
to us when we watch it it sounds like
this extended couple also include
additional cutscenes from a suicide
montage with Deadpool and a clip in
which she kills Hitler as a baby that
freaked out test ah yeah yeah so it just
kills a baby shrimp kills a baby not a
all babies are good I guess I'm not
getting there anyway Eric good let him
live
[Music]
okay everybody with Disney's expected
merger with Fox fans have been very
excited by the prospect of the x-men
Deadpool Fantastic Four Doctor Doom
Silver Surfer all these guys joining the
Marvel Cinematic Universe but but in the
past in the past few days we learned
that the deal might not happen so Disney
owns Marvel of course and it has offered
to buy out Fox's film and TV properties
for fifty 2.4 billion dollars but now
media giant Comcast has made a massive
counteroffer to Fox they have up
Disney's offer with a 60 billion dollar
offer now if Fox sells to Comcast for us
that would mean any hopes to see
Wolverine and Iron Man and the movie
together are dead cancelled now look
there's a lot of inside baseball
business politics involved with this but
it affects the characters and stories we
love so I thought it'd be really useful
to quickly break down how all of this
works and what that means cool everybody
cool basically there are six major media
companies that owned most of the TV and
movies that you watch Disney is the
first they own Marvel Star Wars Pixar
Disney animated movies in the
live-action ones like The Lion King
movies coming out so ABC shows like
agents of shield Fox owns the x-men and
Deadpool franchises Fantastic Four also
alien and avatar and all the Fox and FX
shows like The Simpsons and Legion
then there's Comcast they own Universal
Studios and the Jurassic world series
Fast & Furious the DreamWorks movies NBC
TV shows and technically the rights to
the Hulk movies if they ever get made
and then there's Time Warner they own
Warner Brothers in the DC movies the
harry potter and fantastic beast movies
ready player one it as well as
everything on HBO and the Turner
Broadcasting TV stuff like Adult Swim
Rick and Morty that's that's under time
Viacom owns paramount including the
mission impossible in Terminator movies
as well as the Comedy Central and in TV
stuff it used to own the CBS network but
CBS is technically its own company that
actually cooperates with Warner the CW
network that's a reverse and flash all
you guys and then Sony is like the
smallest one they own spider-man and
venom they in the early days bought that
over from Marvel they also in Jumanji
and the James Bond movies now streaming
services like Netflix are shaking up
this system Netflix has permission from
Marvel Comics of course to produce TV
series like the defenders universe
daredevil Jessica Jones Punisher Netflix
also produces stranger things of course
which is a really big deal but basically
we're looking at x-men and Deadpool
either joining Team Marvel Star Wars
Pixar or team Jurassic world fantastic
furious Hulk
fast and furious not fantastic though
for any Wolverine plus Hulk movie to get
made universal would have to get like
special permission from Marvel to do
that night out Marvel would never allow
that because they have their own very
popular Hulk in their Cinematic Universe
who can't just star in his own movie
because of this weird deal now Marvel
has agreed to a special deal with Sony
to co-produce the spider-man homecoming
series but that deal more so benefited
Disney Marvel because of course they
could feature Spidey and Civil War in
infinity war which is huge for them now
the reason this is all happening guys is
because of money and distribution
Comcast not only owns NBC Universal but
they that's the production side they
also own the massive cable network that
delivers his content to you now Disney
is trying to compete with that they're
working on a streaming service to rival
Netflix so that if you want to watch
like a Star Wars movie or anything from
Marvel or Pixar you got to go through
their app that they're gonna announce in
the next couple years essentially
Comcast is trying to stay in the game
and keep Disney from absorbing all the
most popular franchises boxed meanwhile
is losing money because a lot of their
ties are with like print media okay so
for us this is really just a question of
what's more important is having all of
our favorite characters under one big
tent so they can big make big crossover
movies together important or is avoiding
a potentially big brother in future
where one family friendly company
filters all of our entertainment
important to us what do you guys think
the laptop
I mean I'm supposed to say avoiding the
was that the big brother Ian no I'm with
you it's more fun if Ironman that's the
combo you guys you guys always wanted
149 dollars a month which is what they
could do yeah I think that's that's the
real fear is if imagine there's another
Netflix out there but all of your
favorite movies are on that streaming
service and then they can charge you
$150 a month or a year or whatever it is
you have to pay that to be able to watch
these things in your home I mean we're
the future we're film exhibitors are you
know small town movie theaters are
closing all across the country there's
some places where you can only watch
movies on streaming devices and if I
mean there's a scary future there's a
scary version of the future where the
Marvel movie sucked
at one point you know what I mean like
that like there's not it's not an
automatic given like oh they took all
the good things it's like no they took
things that were going well so if you
want your studio to have something go
invest in good writers and good
directors and make good things and hey
now you'll have one too yeah honestly
like if now we wouldn't want Disney to
take over DC right because like these
are we wanted to close the loop on
Marvel and just make the Marvel that we
already know good to its fullest and
that's the reason I think that Sam and I
are probably like it'd be fun if they
could put those characters together but
aside from that ya probably don't also
own DC and also and everything else but
just make your the best content that you
can make stop being so derivative and
like oh we just we have this property we
need to make a venom movie because of
the rights of it it's like just make
really good stuff and then people go to
that and that's where we'll put our
dollar so yeah I don't mind putting I'm
not loyal to the broadcaster's whatever
I'm not loyal Netflix leaving I'm loyal
to good content that's how they that's
how you can make sway public opinion
that I get I understand that point also
I have read about like some like that
Comcast was offering a cash offer which
I'm not gonna even dive into what that
means but I just imagine like just maybe
a from Comcast showed up with a bunch of
duffel bags of 60 million dollars and
was just like hot like fall over the
fence at Fox it was like we own you now
it's not it's not not stock not that not
properties but literal like five years
that's just what it's worth like they'd
have to sell off certain things I think
the other concern might be the fact that
right now Fox has done some really cool
things allowing some of these movies to
be r-rated so you've had some Deadpool
and Logan was it was great
arguably because it was our rate and
they were allowed to explore some more
adult themes that you would never see in
an MC movie Kevin Feige I'd never make
it alright I don't know if a GU that
I've heard that I mean there have been
talks at least were like there's room
for our rated contact there is they just
haven't done it yet I mean that I think
the Netflix stuff is a good example of
them at least dipping their toe into it
it is like you don't need to get into
the difference between like TV and the
movie side Amaro but that is the MCU and
they are trying a little bit so it's not
impossible I yeah they would happen in
the future also it's under the Marvel
banner so it doesn't mean like it's
under the Disney ban the Disney logo
doesn't come up first the Marvel one
does even though we know where that what
that actually comes from they have more
freedom they're able to say curse words
blow the f-word in their movies they can
say him a couple times at least oh dang
it
yeah exactly right any like how could
they say that overall no this is like it
either way it's not really great like I
like I know we can just say like Disney
shouldn't own everything but both
scenarios aren't the best like Comcast
Universal shouldn't own everything
either yeah I mean if Fox is gonna go
somewhere
of course rather go back with the rest
of its family rather than like weird
rights to a Hulk movie that will never
get made a universal right but let us
know what you think about this down
below and whether you'd prefer to see
Deadpool in the x-men exist in their own
creative movie universe that sometimes
r-rated and not connected to Disney and
maybe Wolverine fighting Black Panther
is just too cool of a possibility to
turn down if that's how you feel which
is kind of how I feel but now let us
move on to our new our sirs news
lightning them Sam are you ready cuz
you're up first
Sam at CrossFit Jesus Junior
don't meet senior who do you think is
the best choice to be the main villain
in Matt Reeves the Batman
ooh go with Hugo Strange I know he's not
like the best like looking one if you
put him on the poster but like he always
creates monsters and I feel like that
because I may be a fun take to go with
the Batman movies you can go ahead and
disagree with me all you want the
comments but hey there you go Theresa
varville wants to know if you could get
to a spin-off series based off one
character from Game of Thrones it could
be a prequel series of the character is
dead who would you want the show to
follow the read change my answer later
right now I'm just thinking of sir
Barristan Selmy yeah I just like he was
around for like all the stuff that they
talked about that was actually really
cool I and and I only say him there's
actually other characters that I
probably would rather be the lead but I
say him just cuz he's the one we know
yeah lightning ad1 jakku wants to know
what movie gamer series our book are you
looking forward to the most in the
second half of 28 you look or game i'll
gosh lightning lightning in the second
half all of them may be just what are
you excited about I think works I mean
I'm not North Korea's current potato who
would you cast to play the Fantastic
Four and Doctor Doom in the MCU
plays like where's four characters man
okay Doctor Doom I would like to see
someone complicated hmm Mads Mikkelsen
is Doctor Doom and then for I don't know
read let's do by the way mines a name of
the wind petrol in store
and then we could do who's a funny funny
storm Kumail Nanjiani and then as Reed
Richards who's a nerd who's smart Thomas
Middleditch and then he's not a person
of color and then as Oh Julian Dennison
as his real name Ricky Ricky Baker
there's a lot of names I just throw
around there's a top one okay next up
let's take a look at what we got in the
pipeline four videos coming out on this
channel in the next week of course it's
han solo time so we're gonna be doing a
big Easter egg breakdown we're also
gonna talk about the surprise cameo mr.
Darth and Maul why and how did he get
there there's a reason we're also gonna
look at who are the Marauders I believe
Sam's gonna be looking at that way leave
it as a secret we got a real fun thing
that we're gonna be doing over the next
month or so so there's a clue on my
Instagram all right and now comes the
time for a 15-second shout-out where
each of us the student sings to talk of
them ramble about whatever one same why
don't you start okay if you guys like to
learn fun trivia facts you should check
out every little thing it's a fun
podcast where people call in and then
the host goes finds and finds an expert
on the thing and they like have them
talk about like the question they had
which is really great like those signs
that say like Oh your cars being watched
by aircraft is that actually real how do
you build on the ground tunnels how do
how do people pee in poop in space you
ever have those questions check out the
podcast it's real good yeah my shoutouts
for the new Winnie the Pooh true
we feel everything what should happen if
you forget about me Simeone fair I never
forget about you pay promise change
things fill up your turn I pass for
right now to put you in this position
what's happening brain oh I figured one
out it was the Patrick Rothfuss book
series the Kingkiller Chronicle is I'm
ready for why matter I think it's coming
this year but it could back to Philip
Devon is our editor on social media what
is it you can be on camera they don't
want you to clap for Devon in the
comments yeah yes okay well now tribute
question that we asked before when
George Lucas originally conceived the
character of Han Solo he based Hans
smooth-talking swagger on a famous
director who was that director let's
start down here this is an actual answer
my it's not great from fimo orson welles
because that's a--that's an actual
director that makes sense yeah that's
good Maude Rhodes Landis as in John land
yes yeah Sam said Stevie Spielberg the
cute little miniature version of Stevie
Animaniacs the baby version over here
too with baby quentin tarantino's is
very smooth talkin swagger baby alright
so correct answer correct answer is
Francis Ford Coppola
in the back of my brain but I didn't
know how to spell
who knew that any directors are like
smooth director to be like that I never
thought of a director to act like him
but Stevie Spielberg seems pretty close
alright so our winner is you did good
well Sam we'll do our goodbyes but first
we're gonna quickly run through our
story in other news headlines that we
have time for let's have my would you
like to read the headline and then I
will have to make a joke at the end of
each a mind a cleverly a Star Wars a
solo a Star Wars story was shipped out
to movie theaters under the codename red
cup as in the Solo cups and they
actually forged a business relationship
together as well oh ooh well red cup
certainly a clever version the codename
for Avengers infinity war oh snap west
world actor Jimmy Simpson jokingly
confirmed a fan theory that his
character William and liam mcpoyle from
It's Always Sunny in Philadelphia are
the same person
Oh West world
I thought the HBO show with tons of
incest was Game of Thrones because
mcpoyle they're all in next up a news
report shows that some of the most
popular baby names in 2017 we're
inspired by Marvel characters including
Parker Wade pepper and Loki
you mean that up there he's like look at
my blade Damon Lindelof said that his
upcoming Watchmen series on HBO would be
totally different than the graphic novel
but that he grew up around but that he
grew up reading Watchmen with his father
and care deeply about it what a lifelong
superfan what more could guy what more
could a guy what Alan more could a guy
want yeah yeah the news the writers of
solo a Star Wars story confirmed that
Lando Calrissian is in fact pansexual
okay so that would explain why the
original line was Han Solo my man or my
woman or my droid or my anything cuz I'm
pansexual and I don't discriminate keep
going with sexual partners because
that's what that means
he really would have put his finger in
l3 I think that's yeah good we didn't
really know what that meant but now we
do we get more viewers during the video
[Music]
before watching the end of these videos
I mean just count in the comments saying
one of you were to do I would say first
in a single-file line
common skill none of people I'm sorry
Sam was a winner and he just wants to
win right now man may I thank you to
everyone for watching this week's
episode of new rock stars news if you
want to follow our hosts oh I'm up first
Sam basher at Sam basher also Eric Vasa
da boss it's in the game I really want
to do voice work and that's how I want
to say that he's gonna submit this for
our voice work I do EA sports it's in
the game one take yeah one takes and
this is when they call me also fill up
and go follow them fimo everywhere that
matters sure probably could you say my
leg another places can you say mine Liz
if you're a Disney Princess for your
voice real can you get kind of KB red
this is the winner so but my carrot
everywhere that matters the winners
don't owe you you definitely trip me up
the winners and losers of the trivia
question we're hoping to hear but I
won't won't apply any of them comment
down below
tweet at new rockers or share it around
and subscribe to new rock stars for more
deep dives and the stuff that you love
see you next time bye bye
so you'd let baby Hitler live I'd kill
the parents we do there's history all
the other anti-semites